monkeypox a viral disease with major
outbreaks spreading in the u.s and
europe is posing a lot of questions so
wired spoke with epidemiologist dr
danielle ompad to learn more about the
look spread and treatment of monkey pox
the biggest question people are asking
is what does monkey pucks look like
the first lesions that you will probably
see
are flat and red and they can be on the
face and spread to the arms and the legs
your hands and feet now i will say
during this outbreak we have seen that
people have fewer lesions than they have
in previous outbreaks the rash which
usually companies flu-like symptoms
begins first as flat and red then it
turns into raised in red
then pimple like bumps
and finally scabs
sometimes the flu-like symptoms appear
before or after the rash but for some
the rash is their only symptom
it can look different you know depending
on your pigment but essentially the
features like flat bumps to raise bumps
to pustules to the scabs that is going
to be consistent and it's the color may
change
if you have monkey pox how long are you
contagious
you are contagious for as long as you
have the rash until the scabs fall off
and new skin forms over where the scabs
are that could be two weeks or longer
depending on how long it takes you to
heal so what type of virus are we
dealing with
monkey pox is an orthodox virus that's
related to smallpox and vaccinia virus
vaccinia virus is actually the virus
that is used in the vaccines for
smallpox and monkeypox it definitely
causes less severe disease than smallpox
how does this virus spread
monkeypot spreads in different ways it
can be spread person to person through
direct contact with infectious rash
scabs or body fluids intimate physical
contact such as kissing or cuddling or
sex whether or not there is penetration
and it can also be transmitted by
touching items like clothing or linens
that previously touch the infectious
rash or body fluids and then pregnant
people can also spread the virus to
their fetus through the placenta
how can we reduce our risk of getting
monkey
pox in terms of protecting yourself you
might want to think strategically about
being in close contact with people with
skin to skin contact you don't want to
kiss cuddle or have sex with somebody
who has monkey pox and you want to avoid
contact with objects and materials that
a person with monkey pox has used you
don't want to share eating utensils or
cups and you should wash your hands i
mean we should be doing that anyways but
you definitely want to make sure that
you're washing your hands especially
before eating or touching your face
if you as an individual
see that you have a rash you're not sure
what the rash is but it might look like
bug bites it might look like chicken pox
make sure that you're not in close
contact with people and try to prevent
spread in case it is monkey pox if it
starts to be very painful if it starts
to spread you might want to go to your
doctor and be assessed to see if you
have monkey pox how do you test for
monkey pox
in order to test for monkey pucks they
require a swab from a lesion as soon as
you have lesions you can start testing
for monkey pox so it'll be about a week
or two before you could test
so who's most likely to get monkey pox
anybody can be infected with monkey pot
in the current outbreak the majority of
people have been male and they have been
gay bisexual or other men who have sex
with men however anybody can be infected
and i need to make that clear because i
want people to realize that if they're
around people who have the monkey pox
rash they're at risk for infection
people who are immune compromised are at
risk for more severe monkey pox
infections and may also be
at risk for complications and even death
as the latest public health emergency
declaration from the world health
organization monkey box has people
worried but unlike the beginning of
covet 19 there are existing treatments
in vaccines for most people the
treatment options are just to treat the
symptoms there is a small supply of a
drug called teapox which is techoviramat
it's an fda approved drug for the
treatment of human smallpox disease it
is not approved for monkeypox but tpox
has been administered to some people who
have more severe cases of monkey pox and
so that has been used but not widely
there are vaccines available ginios is a
live virus vaccine it's administered
with two shots in the arm about four
weeks apart and it takes about two weeks
after the second dose for you to have
maximal immune response there will be
quite a bit of cross reactivity for
smallpox and monkeypox because the
viruses are relatively similar so the
effectiveness for smallpox was estimated
to be relatively high and i would
anticipate the vaccines will be highly
effective for monkey pox as well
you